guten tag mein name ist vanessa auch mal
wanne genannt und heute werden wir
wieder babel thies testen und zwar nicht
von kam bei so wie letztes mal sondern
von einem auch sehr sehr guten wenn
nicht sogar besserem betty laden gerade
wie so ne sk 18 werbung und dieses mal
dachte ich mir warum zum teufel mache
ich mir diese gottverdammte mühe und war
mit einer tiefkühltruhe quer durch
berlin wenn es doch so was wie
lieferservice gibt ja okay kann bei
hatte halt keinen lieferservice und
dieses teehaus wo ich jetzt bestelle das
liefert zu mir seit corona plan war es
alles zu bestellen aber dann habe ich
gesehen wie viele titel haben und heute
wir nicht alles bestellen deswegen
bestellen wir die besten sache auf jeden
fall müssen die beliebtesten tees rein
da wir den bürger milchzucker wenig eis
normal so schwartze us-armee ich bin
jetzt mal gespannt was der unterschied
zwischen denen ist einfach diese
bestellung wird so teuer
grüner oolong tee mit osman tous blüten
ausland to one piece die gibt's halt
nicht diese crazy erdbeeren
babbels wie man sich so ein bild
vorstellt das ist so ein richtig
original taiwanesischer tälern
frischkäse café taverny sascha team mit
leicht mehr ist wo man sät an seetang
bohnen mit seetang weil die waffen
müssen wir auch unbedingt mitnehmen die
sind so lecker wie viele habe ich jetzt
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12 13 40 ja das
reicht 69 eur 80 okay ich hoffe die
freuen sich auf diese bestellung vor
allem war ich vorhin tischtennis spielen
und habe es mir sowas von verdient die
bestellung ist abgestellt
der laden sagt 40 minuten dann sind die
getränke hier ich bin mal gespannt weil
ziemlich viele sind aber wir sehen uns
gleich oh mein gott das hatte dann 38
minuten bevor wir mit dem test starten
können nato stopp bei laktoseintoleranz
komisch dass sie nicht sagen wie viel
man eigentlich brauchen eine dritte
positiver punkt nummer eins papier
strohhalm positiver punkt nummer zwei
papier becher und papier deckel also
seine papier plastik mit negativer punkt
dasteht jetzt nur neun drauf also von
der farbe her würde ich sagen die macher
punkt noch ein negativer punkt man sieht
ja jetzt gar nicht die farbe ich meine
es ist gut das ist kein plastikbecher
ist aber jetzt kann man halt wirklich
nicht sehen was das für sie so aus also
ob dna
sie haben den kassenbon marias ok bevor
wir mit irgendwas staaten brauche ich
unbedingt die waffen diese
taiwanesischen waffeln sind wirklich
helfen diese mit tapioka perlen gefüllt
minute
und die zweiten sind mit vanillepudding
gefüllt die sind wirklich der schritt
kommt zum perfekten zeitpunkt mit
tapioka perlen
wir arbeiten uns von 1 bis 14 uhr unter
vielleicht bis 12 zu mir leid ist ein
bisschen warm hier drin also falls ich
schwitze der erste nummer eins ich habe
den lösungen von daten einfach so rein
können wir sehen wie es aussieht von in
der perlen milch tee den gab es auch bei
come by ich glaub ich auch doppelt yoga
das ist super der perlen wichtig und da
ist einfach ein kilo tapioka perlen grin
probieren
bruno berlin nicht was mir gleich
auffällt ist dass mir perlen nicht ein
bisschen zu schwaches ich finde das
könnte schon stärker nach tee schmecken
aber sehr gut sehr gutes aroma sehr
lecker 15 uhr schade dass man den termin
steht dort nicht laktosefreie kriegt
nummer zwei ein schwarzer us-armee
schwarzer astra sagt mir jetzt nichts
muss ich ehrlich sagen die farbe ist
identisch zum perlen wichtig hier könnt
ihr ganz klare sehen wie viele tapioka
perlen eigentlich drin sein sollten aber
sonst sieht er genauso aus wie die
perlen wichtig dass wenn ich gespannt
war nicht direkt den geschmacks
vergleich machen kann an das lumia ein
bisschen
frischer den finde ich besser als die in
perlen nicht in der pflicht ich jetzt
auch nur neun von zehn der 15 mein gott
das ist so lecker liebe diese test
videos kann ich das noch sagen gekehrt
es mir aber das ist halt relativ gleiche
these sind tee nummer drei sein lippi
schwarztee dafür habe ich auch ein
anderes glas cola dosen cola sieht aus
wie ein bisschen wie cola der schwarze
tee sollte man viel zucker nehmen du
hast range das schmeckt wie schwarztee
und nur ganz leicht spürt man so ein
litschi geschmack der ist überhaupt
nicht präsent ist nicht so als ob man so
ein 40 dringend er einfach nach böse
schmeckt das ist nur so eine note ganz
im hintergrund also dafür dass unser
beliebtes war habe ich mir was anderes
vorgestellt allerdings ganz leicht daran
liegen dass man viel zucker nehmen soll
und nicht wenig vier von zehn 41 kommt
die empfehlung des hauses romstedt olang
milch tee wieder seien wieder aus wieder
fehlende oder ja bei dem große durch den
geschmack wirklich zu schwach
wahrscheinlich das schmeckt gut aber da
könnte man auch um die milch trinken 6
von 10 05 nummer fünf aus man tus
olympia
ein kind kein wichtig der sieht aus wie
einfach nur eingebürgert wir probieren
wir dabei ihr mal das ist eine
empfehlung des hause ist kann gar nicht
sagen wie das schmeckt das schmeckt
blumig wie von aromatisch also zattoo
mein gott c von zehn ich weiß nicht was
dieser tee hat jetzt noch mit litschi
perlen da drin bombe der aus man toll
und empfehlung lecker lecker schmecker
der zucker kann es ja nicht sein weil
über ihr gleich wenig zucker ist lecker
es jetzt sind aber schwer für die
anderen mitzuhalten nummer sechs ist
auch eine tmc lung des hauses grüner
formosa tsg zum riediger früchtetee mit
litschi geil wie unspektakulär der
andere grad auslandeinsätze baby also ja
wir maracuja orange apfel grüner tee so
ganz süße orangenscheibe werde die
frontscheibe sie doch zieht doch einfach
lecker aus der grüne tee ist sehr bitter
das ding muss wahrscheinlich wieder züge
auf eine ende haben um diese bitte hat
vom tee wegzukriegen
man hat auch so ein bisschen frucht
pampe von den maracuja mittlerweile ist
auch mein motto wenn man sein getränken
nicht kauen kann was hat es dann über
film wert ist schon länger ich muss aber
sagen ich schmecke nicht so viel hoch da
raus weil ich einfach nur bitteren
geschmack aber optisch ist der schon mal
ganz weit vorne
ich sag mal so sieben von zehn muss man
sich am ende auch mal die frage stellen
ist es ein hausmann tus oder nicht keine
empfehlung des hauses aber sehr lecker
klingend tees mit frischkäse coffee
frischkäse tt trophy
frischkäse t leute immer das muss man
auch mal zeigen der frischkäse sitzt so
obendrauf
hier haben wir unseren frischkäse
[Musik]
fiebrig lese ein bisschen aus wie kunst
kann man sagen guck mal der frisch den
ist zurückgekommen
[Musik]
also man schmeckt das top ich dass er
jetzt hat doch es hat auch schon länger
ich bin gerade voll wird bei wenn man
tobey schmeckt dann schmeckt das mal so
ultra süß und sehr präsent das ist jetzt
eher wie bei dem lied jona rom
ich glaube sechs von zehn es passend
dafür kommt zurück in die zauberkugel
nacht frischkäse café mal gucken was der
frischkäse kaffee so kann
wieder eine gute schicht frischkäse oben
drauf und das können wir jetzt in unser
glas ihres klasse geht es nicht so
appetitlich aus abersee der geschmack da
konnte man nicht angeben ob man süß oder
nicht süß haben will jetzt weiß ich
warum ich immer sagt mit wenig zucker
hier habe ich das nicht gesagt und es
ist gott verdammt noch mal süß gut acht
von zehn auf jeden fall lacht und zurück
mit dem special vor auf den freue mich
mal mit der startnummer 9 haben wir
einen bio matcha latte mit tapioka
perlen deckel auf die leute wenn euch da
nicht das wasser im mund zusammen läuft
dann kann ich euch nicht helfen
matcha latte ist einfach das leckerste
was auf dieser welt gibt die sogar
laktosefrei bei der matcha latte kann
man nämlich sagen laktosefreie milch
zehn von zehn meine damen und herren
wenn jeder schluck so schmeckt als ob es
dein erster war dann ist es was gut ist
falls ihr mancher nicht kennt
mannschaften sehr eigenen geschmack und
man muss es ein paar mal probieren und
dann irgendwann mag man es plötzlich
im gerade hat mit den profi frischkäse
tee und jetzt haben wir die biotope
schwarztee latte mütter nummer 10 an den
start wie diese tapioka perlen immer als
so eine bombe darauf fallen
das sieht halt auch schon einfach wieder
aus wie dsds schmeckt auch einfach
wieder perlen nicht ein bisschen habe
ich das gefühl dass unser gehirn einfach
noch nicht bereit ist für solche themen
weil letztere lee die meisten sachen
gleich schmecken bis da wird man
irgendwie noch das gefühl die einzelnen
getränke auseinanderhalten zu können bei
dem nicht so ganz ist wieder perlen
wichtigen ganz bisschen trophy geschmack
schmeckt super aber jetzt auch nicht so
super besonders das waren keine tapioka
perlen es waren diese braunen zucker
gelees und die braunen zucker de ist
verstehe ich
die schmecken wie zu weiche tapioka
perlen aber schlechter als tapioka
perlen so haben wir noch zwei noch
zweiter ist jetzt kommt unser wts ist
auch der einzige der schau mich ist die
farbe ist interessant der geruch ist
abstoßend abersee tagen ist doch super
wenn die city mit leichtem erster roman
seetang wohnen mit seetang
[Musik]
ich muss mal von diesem sieg haben
gedanken runterkommen okay kein sieg
kein see twittern kein seetang gott
verdammt ist das lecker war ja ich frage
mich wie viele leute den wirklich dann
am ende des tages bestellen ja
entscheidet also wer hat die auswahl und
sagt so und hoffen ein café maria
hellwig die bitte den einen mit seetang
ja genau der mit seetang ich weiß es
kann man auch essen aber ich will es
trinken ich will seetang trinken wollte
ich gleich wie baby so ein videodreh und
sagen ich verteile bubble tea sun 100
leute und dann gehe ich einfach mit
diesen an gefangenen tees nach draußen
und japan
was tut mir körper und unser letzter tv
heute
ladies and gentlemen sich tee mit
sonnenblumen und leti kokos gele und
natürlich ohne jetzt auch schaumig er
siebter
lokatis dieses biotop all diese skurrile
in einem wunderschönen sonnenblumen
ich hoffe das schmeckt jetzt ich mach
mal ohne ko ko spielen interessant für
sich schmecken
die sonnenblume schmecke ich noch nicht
und so raus also ich finde bei diesem
ganzen milch thies war es nicht so
schlimm
das nicht so wie zucker drin ist bei dem
test außer bei unserem aus mantos oolong
tee finde ich dass die teams ohne mich
auf jeden fall mehr zucker verliehen
irgendwas macht bei dem anderen konnte
ich das kokos litschi herausschmecken
kombination mit dem ts die so
geschmacklos weil ich mich so ganz
leicht aber das ist halt so dass für
unser letzter t könnt es euch vielleicht
schon denken platz eins geht an die
matcha latte mit tapioka phd rossmann
tussauds land ist ganz nach hinten dran
gefolgt von perlen milch tees ich bin
richtig happy dass es alles in
pappbechern gekommen ist und
geschmacklich muss ich auch sagen ich
würde mich freuen wenn ich lieber nur
trinken würde anstatt so starbucks
cappuccinos weil die sind ein möglich
voller zucker und fett und man kann sich
auch eine andere art der frischen und
deswegen ist ganz gut dass dieser bald
die hat gerade ist weil muss ja nicht
immer diese erdbeeren bubbles und sowas
nehmen da muss man aufpassen da kann man
sich gut verstecken also aufpassen wenn
jetzt euren kindern gibt und ja ich hab
gehört
tt muss gehört werden und mein fazit ist
dass es sehr lecker ist taiwanesischen
betty leben ja ich bringe das jetzt
alles mal ganz kurz ein kühlschrank und
für mich gibt es in diesen tagen